so my guest today is colin holback who's
a filmmaker producer director
specifically the reason for this
interview is a recent film that came out
documentary i think it's a six episode
uh series with hbo called into the storm
which he goes and takes a deep dive into
q
q anon 17. if you remember that whole
thing that was going on the last few
years and uh it's very interesting what
happens
uh what he learns about it and we're
going to take a deep dive into it today
with the interview so with that being
said colin thank you so much for making
the time for being a guest on
valuetainment thank you for offering the
spot
[Music]
your background your filmmaker you've
done a lot this is not your first rodeo
you've done this multiple times so you
know maybe first tell us why
this intrigued you so much where you
wanted to find out who's behind cue
well it was back in
i guess september of 2018 you know i was
peripherally aware of q anon at the time
it wasn't as
as well known i guess as it is now
obviously um
but what piqued my interest
was the banning of q anon on reddit
there was a big subreddit focus to this
topic that i knew virtually nothing
about
and then that's when i said well what
was something that was uh you know so
uh
so scandalous or so problematic that it
warranted being banned and might this be
a sign of things to come you know my
background was actually in digital rides
i'd spent the last 10 years or so
kind of on the front lines fighting for
digital privacy online i'd made a film
back in 2013 called terms and conditions
may apply which is about the unholy
alliance between corporations and the
government what they take away every
time we click i agree online so you know
that was my background thinking about
digital uh free digital um
digital privacy and so i came to this
with the same question around digital
free speech
so that's where i came at the story from
initially and and of course i was also
fascinated by the idea of uh you know
who who was behind this whole thing and
and might unmasking who he was bringing
the uh
what was sort of a game still in 2018 to
a logical conclusion
yeah again uh obviously a fascinating
documentary but uh uh if what from your
uh uh from the moment you started doing
researching and q anon would come out
what were some of the
claims they made i mean i know them i
followed them i know most of them but
from your perspective what were some of
the claims that they were making that q
anon is about to unveil to the world on
who's behind pizzagate et cetera et
cetera if you don't mind sharing some of
those
sure
i mean
one of the things about q anon that
makes it a little bit tricky is sort of
a big tense of beliefs so
it's not if you talk to one person who's
a q and on follower they may they often
will not agree on on on the sort of set
of beliefs that they hold with someone
else who's a q a non-believer um
so
what q anon really i think
does because the persona behind cue asks
these questions is it allows people to
uh
sort of build up it's sort of a choose
your own adventure diy belief system um
so you know i do think the one the one
uh primary belief that that underscores
the vast majority of uh the sort of the
philosophy that most people who follow
kyunan
would agree on is that uh they believe
that the the world is run by a a global
cabal of satan worshiping pedophiles you
know and that trump was working with
this government insider aka queuing on
this is the belief
to to bring an end to this cabal and so
this is the quote-unquote plan um that
that uh q anons are supposed to trust
and that at some point in the future the
great awakening would happen
um or the coming of the storm i mean
there's a lot of these key words and
phrases that cue uses and will often
repeat that become um staples in in um
in q and on but what one q a per
believer might say about the storm is
completely different and it shifts over
time
um you know the uh i like you know
there's another one like red october and
even though uh q anon has has is
dwindling now um every october is red
october for them so uh so i think it's
more like there's there's keywords and
phrases that people ascribe meaning to
but they wouldn't necessarily agree on
what that meaning is so when you when
you went in and you started uh
you know researching and taking you know
going into it to learn more about it
what are i mean obviously i know how the
whole thing ends and i think you even
went on
with jim to january 6 i think you were
with him i think you you went in uh
but what were some of the things you
ended up i was with jim on the 6th
so walk me through what happened when
you're going through
what are you learning more about them
you know what did you end up learning
about the whole thing and uh
maybe afterwards we'll talk about what
the experience was like the first time
you spoke to ron
and ron said to you know were your
reactions like wait what you know you
were kind of blown away by so walk us
through what you learned from the
organization and i'll go into a couple
questions afterwards
uh what i learned from from which
organization q anon you know when you
learn about qna and who's behind it
who's running it
more you know how this whole thing came
was it really a high-ranking military
personnel that's running it
right so
you know this theory obviously we spend
a lot of time over the six hours in the
series breaking down the mechanics of q
and on um you know where q on was sort
of forged from
which is chan culture
ron watkins and his father jim watkins
um they have a lot of experience running
the chance i mean uh jim watkins was was
in many ways the
sort of the og when it came to um
bringing it uh both you know to japan
and and and and partially to the states
as well um you know he uh
anyway so they they own and operated
8chan at the time you know q and all got
started on 4chan it was there for q the
sort of anonymous insider who was
posting there where no one could really
figure out who who this individual was
who was
i think you would say that the term is
usually larping live-action role-playing
pretending to be some sort of secret
government insider but a lot of people
believe that it is the secret government
insider and so this is part of the the
game is it does this person really have
access to trump or is this just somebody
who's on uh the chan side screwing with
people right you know and this is
something that people do on the chance
all the time this kind of trolling
trying to get other people to believe
that um there's something that they're
not um that's that's sort of the gold
standard on on on these uh platforms so
this is where q is coming from um cube
moves from 4chan to 8chan pretty quickly
uh back in 2017
uh and then come early 2018 um
jim watkins and ron watkins and their
website become these sort of stewards
for for queue
raw watkins gets mentioned in the
beginning of uh that that transition you
know and i think people start being like
all right well you know what's what's
their level of involvement in all of
this um that's why i got in touch with
with jim and ron uh in the beginning was
partially to talk with him about the
free speech issues that um the queue was
he was kind of drumming up um in the in
the internet circles
um but also because if anybody knew who
was behind q anon you know it would be
those closest to the source it would be
those with the actual technical data um
and because everything is anonymous is
of course very tricky but that doesn't
mean that
he wouldn't make mistakes that there
wouldn't actually be ip addresses or
other things that could help lead you to
whoever was behind this whether it was
an individual or a group which is also
what most to follow cue believe
so
at what point
uh
did you finally realize that they were
the two behind the whole thing
well after that first time uh
visiting them in the philippines which
is where they were running uh which is
where they were more or less running
their operations out of sort of a
mixture of the philippines and japan but
uh after that first trip i was like gosh
these guys are these guys are suspicious
you know you got the feeling right off
the bat
what's that you got the feeling right
off the bat right off the bat yeah the
way they were answering questions the
the
what they were what they were hiding
sort of the clues that were coming from
omission their knowledge base
the way they would interact um sometimes
they would know too much sometimes they
would know too little
and i don't think that they were really
prepared for me that first time either
and their chores their stories
completely changed the next time i went
and filmed with them they kind of
recalibrated it would seem behind the
scenes which is also what someone who
was working for their organization
relayed to me
so
um you know from that point on it became
a very much a kind of cat and mouse game
with myself and with ron and with jim
you know and ron remained kind of
my top suspect until that summer
when
um he presented me with a pile of
forensic evidence that pointed to the
individual that he claimed was behind it
which ron said it was steve bannon and
that he'd known that it was steve bannon
since uh nearly the beginning and of
course steve bannon is uh you know
was sort of the architect of the 2016
trump campaign and sort of a master of
digital strategies so he's a he's a good
suspect if you're looking for a guy yep
um so at that point i was like okay well
this is
this seems viable you know how did he
how did he put together this forensic
trail is it is it authentic or not was
it steve bannon or was it wrong you know
those were those became my top two
suspects and we really parsed out what
happened and why i think that happened
in the series ultimately i come to the
conclusion that
you know the whole time ron was more or
less larping as steve bannon trying to
say okay who would be the right person
to lead someone like colin too and maybe
he was a little bit disappointed that uh
nobody had seen his awesome forensic
trail up until that point so uh you know
that's um that's the explanation that i
arrive at in the series
and uh
um
yeah i
did see that uh you know it was a very
uh it was a very credible trail you know
it it uh it it pointed in his direction
in a in a in a way that was hard to
um hard to explain but i think we come
up with a good explanation
did steve mind being the person like did
that become public where people were
thinking it was steve behind the whole
thing
um
sorry say again did steve mind that
people accused him of being behind cue
you know i i don't
i i reached out to steve bannon and his
um you know his uh her personal handler
multiple times i was trying to get an
interview with him about this you know i
eventually said look it looks like
someone's trying to
trying to
set you up kind of as the fall guy for q
um you know
they he was actually open to talking
with me about q anon not because he was
necessarily involved in it but just
because he was interested in the topic
and that just never came to fruition but
i don't know exactly what uh what his
feelings are on at this point i don't
know um since the election if ron
watkins and and steve bannon are talking
i know that ron had been trying over the
course of
maybe many years to get in touch with
steve bannon and that's one of the
things that you see in the series this
idea of me magic of something starting
as just a game or a larp and becoming
real you know um sort of pretending to
have the cue pretending to have access
to the um upper the upper echelon of
government the
the inside circle of trump and then by
the end of the series you see that ron
and and those in his orbit actually do
get that access
um and so you know in the year that's
kind of followed you say well you know
is is ron in touch with steve bannon now
um you know he was advising in those
later days on on
election fraud uh issues so
uh i mean it's it's a
it's an unbelievable exercise in in kind
of will to power i guess you know you
know how sometimes you're sitting with
the uh the psychology about a
criminal
who has pro pride in the fact that i did
it i'm the one that did it but you got
to get him to a point where he wants to
take ownership to make you realize how
tough he is and he says look
you know of course who else is going to
do something this genius of a job you
know yes okay i did it and it's a
private conversation let's just say
you're having with somebody like this
was was that the situation where
he secretly wanted you to know that it
was him behind the whole thing or was he
walking on egg shows making sure you
never found out
that he was the one behind it because
there's a big difference between you
asking the right questions to getting to
the conclusion that you want versus no i
really wanted you to know that i'm the
guy behind it which do you think it was
well you know i think ron is the
linchpin behind it um but but to answer
your question
i
i think the deep down he didn't want the
credit but ultimately he can't
he can't
handle the responsibility of what would
come with that
so we will always be left in a situation
where he has to deny deflect and dodge
but he's going to come as close as he
can to admitting it
um and he's done that any number of
times since the the series the series
aired right um you know he he messaged
me at one point he's like colin you know
i identify more with villains or uh you
know i learned a long time ago that
creating internet personalities that are
larger than life make for a more
entertaining existence
um
you know and i think that he was
yeah he was he was coming as close as he
could to admitting to it without
outright just saying that he was he was
behind it um and because i don't think
he knows what the legal ramifications of
that might be
there could be any number of reasons why
he he wouldn't take it to that to that
um to that extreme
but
one of the questions i still have to
this day
is what were these overlapping networks
working with him behind the scenes you
see some of it in the series right you
see that general flynn is actively
reaching out to um
to
uh big q and on influencers through dms
on twitter um bolstering that behind the
scenes you see another general step in
general paul valailly you know he more
or less wrote the book on psyops and
come 2019 2020. you know he and his um
in his kind of orbit of ex-military guys
or bolstering things so
um
it's it because these networks are
decentralized and can organize you know
remotely i think that's part of why you
see
characters who are spread out across the
globe here
and that makes it harder much harder to
track much harder to know how they're
communicating behind the scenes just how
much coordination is really going on
yeah it's it's amazing when you see
how easy it is to get the world to
believe
um
a conspiracy theory i mean you think
about
on both sides right i mean you you think
about how
the world believed russia was behind the
whole thing the world believed you know
the whole russia dossier and they're
like sitting there saying oh my gosh
this is really happening the the one
side believe queueing on like there's
really something behind us by the way
just out of curiosity well i think
actually you know q anon believers
aren't all on the right there's a you're
right
not insignificant portion of those who
follow cue who are who are on the left
as well um and especially in the last
year uh with with uh people looking for
more control in their lives in
relationship to everything with kovic
yeah um you know we
uh
the eq also started to penetrate new age
communities ufo communities um you know
and and people who are part of those
communities
they're on the right and they're on the
left you know so this is not just a
right-wing
um a right-wing belief system yeah let
me ask you this just that accurate how
much time did you spend on this total
beginning time if you were to put an
hour to it how many total hours did you
put into this oh my gosh i mean well i
can tell you how many hours of footage i
had how many i shot over 1600 hours holy
moly
1600 hours is what you had okay so and
how long was it from the moment you
started the the project to the end when
you were done not cutting editing just
to the end when then you started editing
cutting how long is that time
so that that was um
faster than i could have possibly
imagined so i had been filming on and
off for two and a half years um and we
were producing this thing entirely
independently you know like credit cards
and hopes and dreams and yeah oh my god
it's free came on in
september of 2020 and the series came
out in march of 2021 um i had edited
about a feature film's work yeah i
personally caught about 90 minutes um so
we put the series together in about five
months time we cut the whole thing
so it was just
the one the most intense experience of
my life
getting this out but
timing really mattered with this project
no question about it so here's a
question i want to ask you i interviewed
greg kading who was i think originally
he was working on
uh how
big he got killed okay and he wanted to
find out what happened there and through
investigating who murdered biggie he
learned about who murdered tupac
and and sometimes when you're working on
something like this
and you're going too deep
you'll learn about some stuff that
you're kind of like oh my gosh i really
didn't want to know this about that
person or this person
did you did you learn anything about
anybody where you're like whoa this is
extremely creepy do you ever feel like
you got in too deep where you were
trying to identify who's behind cue
another and then you realize maybe who's
behind deep state
you know i
you see some of it in episode five
um
there's the call behind the scenes with
jason sullivan and bill benny you know
these guys bill benny's and nsa
whistleblower jason sullivan was roger
stone's head of social media strategy
they were trying to get in touch with q
you know that's sort of the moment where
you see
um real power start to
real political power from dc start to
merge with q openly
but you see at the beginning of episode
5 cicada 3 301 you meet thomas
schoenberger you meet um
and when i started to to look into that
world
the world of these uh sort of cicada
guys
um
you know you get a hint at thomas's
background for instance he kind of
implies that he works for intelligence
uh that is a that is a shadowy
organization that um
it's hard to really
you know they're all sending you
signals of smoke and mirrors
um
and that's one of those organizations
where you go like well do i want to look
closer or not
um
you know what
and this is an organization that was was
bolstering queue behind the scenes and
was there at the beginning so when we're
talking about overlapping networks
um cicada3301 sort of generation two of
it i guess you would say um
the one that's more or less helmed by
thomas schoenberger uh you know
what what exactly was their level
involvement um and and why were they
there in the beginning uh
if you start going down the rabbit hole
online of cicada3301 and and thomas
you'll you'll know what i mean
what's their what's their main uh uh
what they believe in cicada 3301
uh
um i mean thomas would say you know uh
he likes to say the phrase
internal renaissance a lot
i
in my experiences with them
they're not they don't all necessarily
agree on uh what what exactly it is that
they want but it's a very smart group of
individuals i know i've met some of them
who are accelerationists right so they
want to
maybe speed things up get get to get to
conflict faster um for whatever reason
maybe it's because they think that's how
we get off uh you know in well i can
give you one reason
they think that
if you
speed things up and you create maybe a
global conflict
and i'm not saying this for all of the
people who are skated just an individual
or two that i talk to from you know who
identifies as that
when you talk about accelerationism
um if you were to have a global civil
war or a global conflict of some sort um
historically speaking during times of
war
way more money gets thrown into
technology way more money gets thrown
into technological advancement so for
individuals who want to see something
like that who maybe want you know space
travel to get here sooner um
they would be less concerned with with
uh sort of peace and more concerned with
how do you get off this rock so that you
know that's
so there might be a portion of them who
would be driving towards that kind of
conflict um
but but again
a certain amount of that is his
assumption and i'm saying that uh
you know this is this is one of those
rabbit holes that
you asked me about yeah that that i'm
i'm looking at the down the edge of and
going do i really want to go down well
we'll come back to the civil war
conversation but i want to continue with
the reason i ask this question is
because i grew up with a family that
believed in communism that was their
religion and you know karl marx was the
greatest thing since sliced bread so i
read communist manifesto to get my
beliefs
as a communist stronger
as a person who
was wanting to
you know believe in this thing even more
and the more i read the book the more i
more i argued the book the more i was
like
this doesn't make any sense i don't know
if i agree with this what are you
talking about so
i found myself my own opinions changing
after reading the book instead of
thinking if i read the book my belief in
you know communism could potentially go
higher so the the way i'm asking you the
question is from the perspective of
did you go in because you know how they
talk about deep state okay who is deep
state every time you're like well the
people who have power
because you know they'll say things like
there's a
major major percentage of america that
doesn't believe joe biden's the
president it's not just you know 1
million 10 million 50 million it's a
very big portion even some on the left
where they say
so what do you mean you can't answer
this question this is very weird we've
never seen a president say they're not
going to let me answer the question
they're not going to let me talk to you
i'm going to get in trouble i've never
heard a president say something like
this so people are questioning that so
i think we saw something similar happen
after trump got elected right you know
a lot of folks on the left were kind of
waiting for the mueller report to to
release yeah that was going to be the
thing yeah going to take down trump and
then the election would all be reversed
yeah so it almost feels like the same
thing playing out just yeah but yeah but
the question i'm trying to ask you is
the following here's what i'm not asking
you about the election part the election
part is the election part you know we
know joe biden's the most popular
president of all time we all know that
that's 81 million votes uh uh
you know that's a record-breaking number
we know that number what i'm asking you
is for you you that have this experience
uh the deep state okay
so is really the president the president
like i remember one time i'm talking to
uh uh uh
one of the cia agents i don't know if it
was a director of cia but wanted to see
a mo
i'm talking to one of these guys and i
said
i don't know maybe he likes to he does a
lot of uh yeah i don't i don't know i
can bring it up and tell you who was but
i asked the question i said i don't know
you know how they say like when bush did
the interview with jimmy fallon and he
said so when he became the president did
they take you to area 51 yep do you know
what happened to kennedy yep do you know
if we have any aliens yup can you tell
me anything nope
so i don't know if you remember that
exchange with the interview
so but i don't know if i'm comfortable
having a president that's potentially
only going to be in charge of the
greatest country in the world for four
years telling him everything and then
he's going to leave i don't know if that
makes any sense so
it almost like
you need somebody above that to that's
going to be there for a long time when i
interviewed the chief disguise officer
of cia
jonah mendez who uh
her husband was the the one with argo
that whole thing that was taking place
but i'm in dc right in front of white
house i'm interviewing chris so what's a
great quality of a great cia agent do
they need to be good in sales charming
what makes them so special
she said great in sales charming closer
convincing conniving
all of that except one thing
i said what's that
when they save the free world they don't
need the recognition for it like they
don't care to get recognized and they're
going to read the paper the next day and
their name's not going to say cia agent
save the world right okay
so if there is a deep state okay
you know whether it's a soros koch
brothers when they say which president
do you want me to buy this time you know
that joke that was going on for many
years or obama's or clinton's or bush's
or whoever this is not a left or right
thing let's just say there's a deep
state
did you ever re you know researching q
anon because
they were getting in all this criticism
and did you all of a sudden say man [ __ ]
there is a deep state i just don't know
who's behind it i'd love to go
investigate this did that ever happen to
you
well i think that
when you the term the deep state can
have different meanings different people
right you know if what we're talking
about is a
um
like
a group of people in dc who are just
there kind of calling the shots
regardless of if the president is right
or left if we're talking about you know
institutions that that um
you know
whether it's the cdc or you know or or
the epa or whatever whatever institution
you want to pick um you know that that
is trying that needs to make sure they
have a budget every year that um that is
trying to protect their own um you know
these these these large organizations uh
i mean of course they're
that have a lot of power the nsa right
you know that also or the three-letter
agencies that are all kind of jockeying
for power against each other of course
those things exist and of course they
have um far-reaching powers you know
this is one of the reasons that i was so
concerned when i made terms and
conditions may apply what what what can
happen
if some if an organization like the nsa
is able to
know literally everything about a
journalist or politician
and how how can that information be
leveraged and who gets access to that
information
so
um if the deep state is the term to
describe those institutions or the
individuals who are kind of operating
behind the scenes as politicians come
and go
um you know then then it's uh
then it's just a a term for describing
you know basically the establishment
just a new way of saying new way of
saying that
have you ever uh
have you ever been inspired after doing
something like this where you spent 1600
hours of footage two and a half years
did it ever ever get you to say
you know what screw it let me go find
out
who's really in charge
like who's really pulling the ropes
behind closed doors if there is i'm
going to debunk it because i don't
believe anybody's there
and i'm just going to go figure this out
or do you say that's one area i don't
want to screw around with because my
life could be ruined
i think that when you're dealing with
intelligence agencies like that i mean
they're masters of smoke and mirrors
um
it's it is
they
they if they're talking to you then you
have to ask yourself why are they
talking to you why are they telling me
what they're telling me um
you know what what is sort of the the
origin of this narrative i mean i think
there are a lot of journalists out there
who have sources you know in high places
in government
who
when those sources tell them something
you know there's they want access to
that but it's hard to know what the
motives of that individual really really
are so
that
that is a very difficult a difficult
thing to investigate
um
and
uh
usually a lot of time has to pass before
you're even you're able to get any sort
of sense of what might have happened you
know
after certain people have died or the
the stakes related to that information
just don't
aren't as relevant anymore i mean we
still don't really know what happened
with jfk right
we're constantly told yeah it's all
going to be released all the information
is going to come out and yet still to
this day
it hasn't so there are some secrets that
that go beyond the grave it would seem
but uh if you're trying to investigate
something like that in real time um it's
it's very
it's a very dicey game well i i bet if
you announced that that's what you're
going to investigate
i would be willing to bet not a single
single life insurance company would
underwrite your policy
if you and i'm in the insurance world so
here's here's why i'm asking this
question
i'm fascinated by what you did because
uh how quickly did an organization like
this take like do you remember when
anonymous was like oh my gosh anonymous
made another video like hi we are the
anonymous do you remember that so it was
like we talked about anonymous in the
series yeah we um uh and in fact
actually the person who claims to be the
founder of anonymous is is is in the
series aubry cottle um who kind of came
out of he he was he had a chan that he
also created in the early days called
420 chance yeah which is sort of where
anonymous got its start and then
q1 happened and then he kind of came
came out of i guess for
retirement or something it audited from
and uh was like all right well i'm gonna
do what i can to try to try to take this
thing down and so i chronicle a little
bit of his uh his campaign against both
q and on and and against the watkins
this model has been around for a while
it's not a new model it's my it's a
model that's been that goes way
back even before
uh our times no i asked this question
how are those guys an anonymous now you
know there there's so much paranoia
among the people who were there in the
beginning they all they're all concerned
the others are government assets at this
point you know so uh yeah it's it's uh
if nothing else there's there's
a lot of uh division among the ranks
yeah the top i remember i interviewed
john mcafee at his house
and i don't think i've met somebody more
paranoid
than him
if you see his interview he's sitting
there right next to me with a gun
he's sitting there smoking a cigarette
he's got four or five former navy seal
rangers in the back with
ak-47s m16s a guy knocks on the door one
guy comes out
and i've never met anybody that uh
paranoid because at that point
i even asked him a question he said he
said do you even trust your mom i don't
even trust my mom i'm like wow you've
reached at that level i mean how do you
so i can only imagine to be in these
types of communities but the only reason
i ask this question for me is the
following reason
so uh when the discussion comes up about
trump right i think of three presidents
take trump take kennedy take reagan okay
what do the three have in common uh
somebody tried to take uh the life of
reagan
they missed
they were successful with kennedy
of course we have lincoln as well
and then trump
is a anomaly where
you know so i some people thought maybe
that's going to end up happening with a
guy like this because he's so loud and
he's going to piss off the wrong person
right okay obviously
everyone's glad that didn't happen
because the last thing you want is
something like that it would be
catastrophic for many different reasons
but
what do those three have in common maybe
if you also throw lincoln into camp what
do those four have in common well first
i was thinking was was kennedy also in
hollywood but he's not really in
hollywood no he won't have a celebrity
status similarly in a big way yeah i
mean he would be probably the biggest
celebrity
president we've ever had right i mean i
think he would be in that league with
marilyn monroe all of that but what do
they have in common none of them needed
money
none of them did it for money
none of them could be bought
reagan had his own money kennedy's had
their own money and if there is a deep
state the deep state probably doesn't
want to have a leader that doesn't need
them because the deep state likes to
choose people
that they can fund because if they fund
them they can tell them what to do and
that's the
thought of some people that i bring on
as a guest and they present this
argument to me and i sit there and say
if there is a deep state they would not
like a person like kennedy they would
not like a person like lincoln they
would not like a person like
you know a reagan they would not like a
person like trump they got to figure out
a way
to
not give them that kind of power because
they lose a lot of their liberties they
lose the ability to
play the political games that play and
by the way this is nothing new politics
and playing games and playing power has
been going around for thousands of years
so sure yeah the question here is like
who they are that's what i'm curious who
is they that's the that's the question
and i think that it's i think that it's
incredibly complicated and how all of
the and what
what
who's going to make money from what who
has what political agenda who's you know
obviously anyone who has a lot of money
is going to have a lot of influence
anyone who has a lot of influence
economically is going to is going to be
jockeying behind the scenes so um
usually it you can trace it back to who
has the most to lose
and whoever has the most to lose will be
will be fighting the hardest and if they
have the resources then they'll
be money money goes a long way right it
it it has more contr it has it drives
most of these engines if somebody if
somebody agrees you know you're going to
look at
i mean we saw the the influence that
various billionaires have had in
campaigns there's a reason that those
bought the washington post a lot of this
stuff is based on influence and there's
lots of different inflection points for
that influence whether it's the
institutions themselves behind the
scenes where people have connections
whether it's connected in some way shape
or form to the revolving door between
you know corporate america and the
institutions themselves and whether and
and and the sort of i guess as long as
we're talking about rigging the trickle
down from the billionaires and and their
desires at the end of the day uh you
know and i think that to your point if a
candidate runs say it had been bernie
sanders right would he what would have
been the dynamic with bernie sanders and
uh and sort of the billionaires who are
out there would he have taken that money
from them and if not what would be the
opposition to a candidate like that you
know i think you see a similar thing um
with with donald trump where okay he can
fund his own campaign so does that pose
a a viable threat
versus establishment candidates
you know hillary clinton isn't it is the
definition of an establishment candidate
right um so she would be very um well
funded by uh all of these special
interests uh that's i guess the other
term so i guess if you you know that you
you might use to describe
how
how they get the policies enacted that
they want that that um you know keep
wall street happy or keep whoever happy
that you know wants to make money that's
why they put so much money into
political campaigns i mean i always say
this if we if you really want to do
something about what you're describing
as the deep state here the first thing
would be campaign finance reform if you
can get money out of politics you start
to clean up this whole the whole entire
thing all the way down you think that'll
ever happen
um it's it's not impossible you know
do i like the idea that a congressman
spends eighty percent of their time
trying to raise money rather than
spending all of their time uh you know
uh reading the bills and engaging with
their constituency um and that when they
raise that money of course they're
beholden to that money no [ __ ] no i
don't like that i agree with you yeah
you know if we could get rid of that
yeah make all the difference in the
world but um you know i i
and
i wish that more candidates would run on
that platform
you know on a campaign finance reform
because that that is sort of the source
of so many of the issues that we
experience if you want to talk about
where all of the influence comes that
seems to not serve the people it's
because it's special interests
protecting their own interests
using using money and getting policies
that that
benefit them if somebody gave you an
open checkbook and said hey i want to
hire you to go do this call on you you
decide who you want to recruit would you
uh consider taking the uh uh offer of
investigating the deep state and doing a
documentary on them
oh i mean like i said you know i think
that it's
what we're talking about here is is sort
of the establishment and actually i
already made a documentary that breaks
down why this whole system is so broken
it's called what lies upstream
um i used
i used the uh or i spent several years
in west virginia embedded with the
political
um i guess the political elite there you
would say um
after this kind of water contamination
happened and you just watch as all the
special interests and all the money kind
of comes in and then guts any kind of
protections in that state and you can
see how
the lobbyists work in that film you can
uh how the politicians kind of bend to
their will and then you can see how the
people who are working at the
institutions um sort of the analogs
there of the the epa and the cdc at the
state level completely fail the people
because of the political influence over
them so um
you know i think that i've already made
a film that get unpacks with what's
happening there you know at a higher
level if we want to break down what's
going on with the with with the
billionaire class and how the
billionaire class influences politics
and and all and sort of the tapestry of
things that make it so that we end up
with policies that are that aren't good
for the average person i mean that's you
could you could make documentaries about
that until until the end of time i think
the real i i joke about this but really
like i think a lot of documentarians
would be out of a job if there was
campaign finance reform yeah
there's a lot of truth behind that do
you think q anon is done like you think
they're going to show up for 2023 uh are
they going to be back at it again or is
it going to be disguised at a different
organization that shows back up what do
you think happens with the q and on
more closer to the latter okay so one of
the things that q did at the very end
like like a week and a half two weeks
before uh the election and on the
election is more or less when he landed
um also when ron walken stopped running
uh
stop stop being the admin of a [ __ ] um
you know but anyway the what q said was
uh there is no
human on right there's q and there's no
there are nones there is no q a on it
was kind of like
putting a a death nail in this thing and
it became a gaslighting technique from
that moment on so that any time someone
said the phrase q or q and on or call
something q and on
you would you would then hear oh this
person doesn't know what they're talking
about there is no q on this became the
the the like the the clever the
pseudo clever rebuttal i guess to any
time somebody um
like myself made a series about it or
said the phrase q anon which is of
course just just ridiculous but they're
doing it because q said that and i think
the reason the q said that is multi-fold
you know going into the election
um you know
with no degree of certainty who was
going to win but perhaps fearing that
from their perspective that biden would
win
um
you know being labeled as q and on
perhaps would um
would would make one a a pariah
the the pr around q is not great right
now um to be labeled as q anon it's
still pretty toxic
so what we've seen now instead is people
just using all of the keywords and
phrases from q and on is a kind of
just obvious
code to let others know that yeah
actually they are still totally queuing
on they still they're still part of the
club club's still going and the club is
getting glossier you know there was just
an event this weekend called the patriot
double down
you had
if you compared that event which had
hundred dollar tickets to get into it uh
very uh high production value across the
board um you know from the the trailers
to it and i think they had the i'm gonna
say his name wrong but like jim
cassavelli you know the guy who played
uh jesus in town
jim caviezel jim caviezel yeah he was
there talking you know flynn was
supposed to be there uh he pulled out at
the last second but you you had some you
had a lot of high profile people make an
appearance there ron watkins headline
this event and it was a q a on event
everything about it used coded q and on
language to advertise itself there's you
know where we go when we go all uh
it had uh in the logo it was a a seven
and a queen of hearts the cards you know
which which adds up to 17 and that was
not the logo
yeah yeah what's steven called again two
cards with a seven and a q what's the
event called
uh the patriot double down keep going
i'm watching this last weekend you know
and so everybody is organizing and
they're figuring out how to become
political animals yeah and take over the
political landscape so what q is doing
now is it's moving to real political
power and ron watkins is running for
congress that's
you know that was announced in the last
week and a half um so if that gives you
any case if if the guy who i think we
proved to be behind cue in the series is
now running for congress if we saw
someone like marjory taylor green be
able to get into congress a couple years
ago running on a what was largely a you
know a q a on friendly platform um we're
going to see more q and a on candidates
they might call themselves q and on
candidates but that doesn't mean that
they're not
and do you think the opposing side is
going to use that against them
they will try to use it against them but
i don't think it will make much of a
difference
um
you know i think like in the case of ron
he can lie about things or he can and be
caught in those lies he can fool his
followers into thinking that you know
some
some amazing thing is right around the
corner and then it never seems to pay
out or rarely pays out
and it's almost like the more he tricks
them the
the more they like him like the more
clever they think he is so
i don't know if if being labeled as q
anon will
be
terribly detrimental in the upcoming
election cycle because
what they're going to be focusing on
won't be any of the q and on related
beliefs they're not going to talk about
a global cabal of satan worshiping
pedophiles that's not going to be a
talking point the talking points are
going to be
digital censorship
and election integrity and they're not
going to worry about anything else
and for all of the people out there who
have been banned from twitter or banned
from facebook
um they're angry as they should be
and
and they're going to it's going to be
easy to mobilize those individuals and
if they feel like a q anon candidate is
is
going to be the champion of those issues
it's not even going to matter to those
voters i think that they have this whole
other
stable of of beliefs
you know they'll they'll run on just
those two ideas and i've already seen in
in these conferences you know early on
the censorship really hadn't ramped up
yet online
and as it did um they were really able
to to mobilize around that and most of
the speakers it didn't really matter
what the substance was of what they were
discussing all that really mattered was
that they weren't allowed to say it
online and the people who are in the
audience shared that sentiment and so
do they have the potential to be
successful in this upcoming election
cycle
i i think that that the left didn't
realize and some of these tech giants
had no idea what that
that that their actions online would
would uh would result in in in sort of
the opposite i guess of whatever it was
that they were seeking of that yeah
do you think there's a
just out of curiosity i mean you've
obviously spoken on
censorship cancel culture you've talked
about a lot of those things as well in
different various
forms do you think there's a
uh uh
an end game not an end game do you think
do you think this whole concept of
cancel culture what's going on with you
know
dave chappelle or whoever it is that's
uh you know
they're trying to be cancer do you think
cancer culture and censorship
is sustainable to use as a way to bully
people for a long period of time or do
you think eventually people are going to
be like listen stop it it's it's too
much now it's got to stop
well the
um
you know what i'm asking right yeah no i
do know what you mean yeah i mean you
can only
you can only take it so far
and
what's happened now is that people have
who were
you know
banned on on these platforms have moved
elsewhere you know my concern was that
those other platforms the alternatives
would also not be allowed
that there couldn't even be another
place for people to go
um
is it sustainable
i mean
culture
you know it's a constantly changing
beast and there's a lot of people on the
right who know how to how to leverage
that as well you know i think that there
were some very savvy political actors
who saw
this impulse coming from big tech
and from from
this sort of
the
culture of um particularly the far left
that that
could be beneficial politically you know
try to do things that will
will speed it along to the point that
more cancellation or more more
censorship will happen so that you can
then point at that and say oh look at
look at what's going on look at how
we're we're um we're being silenced but
the only way you know you have a right
at all is you it's not it's the it's the
extreme tests it's something like q and
on the test whether or not you really
have free speech right it's not the it's
not it's not easy political dialogue
um i mean there are questions about what
kind of speech online
should we have anonymous speech online i
think we should but what does it say
that somebody in south africa can use
anonymous speech to influence somebody
in america um that's just a new problem
that we haven't really grasped
um but anonymity isn't the problem you
know anonymity is is is is um
sort of a
it's been
the
a a staple in in civil rights in the
past and
in
our ability as a society to to improve
um you know it protects people who who
uh whistleblowers and other things like
that it's how it's often how more
transparency can be brought about and
people don't need to go on facebook like
people can go on facebook and say the
most like rancid [ __ ] you know they
don't need the the uh the shield of
anonymity so anonymity is not not the
issue here you know and i actually don't
think that the country would be nearly
as polarized as it is
i know that it wouldn't be if if digital
privacy hadn't been eroded
right because it was the erosion of
digital privacy over the last 10 years
and the ability of both the government
and corporations and political
operatives ultimately to see everything
that we're doing and then manipulate
that so i used to get asked a lot well
why does it matter what i if they're
monitoring everything i do everywhere i
go and and build a profile all of my
beliefs
right why does any of that matter what's
the cost
well all this is the cost the the hyper
polarization that we experience right
now that's the cost it's the algorithms
being able to
use
our fears and insecurities against us
yeah in the form of these psychometric
profiles to drive us into echo chambers
so that people don't
so people
think it's
almost like a crime to talk to someone
from the other side you know
um and that and and the algorithms also
provided a a you know
a politically operating moment
for
uh operatives in dc who knew how to who
knew how to capitalize on that or for
people like ron walken to understand how
to how to how to feed the algorithms and
and drive attention
so for those who know how they work and
know how to manipulate them they can
build something like humanon
would something like january the 6th
have happened if if people hadn't been
able to be mobilized using beliefs that
kind of bubbled up out of the chance
um or and then found their way onto
youtube
if people weren't on youtube driven
towards more sensational
um and extreme content i don't think so
so if i was to start with something here
i wouldn't start with with limiting the
speech online you know the speech is a
symptom like people being really
the things that people are saying online
right now and that just the level at
which things have gotten is a symptom
of
not having privacy online and i would
start by restoring rights rather than
taking them away so you would give you
would give guys like uh
uh uh what was his name yannopolis uh of
uh what was the guy's name something
yiannopoulos or
uh and alex jones or a uh trump you
would you would say let those guys have
their platform
uh it's not a good idea to censor them
let them speak you know i think that
i think that um
these bigger platforms like twitter and
facebook and all of that
on the one hand you can say well they're
companies they're private companies they
they decide what kind of speech is
allowed on their platform and what kind
is them you know section 230 enables
that
um okay
but
look at the scale of these companies
look at how many people are using
twitter you know if that is the place
where all of the information
if that is the sort of hub of
information if that's the place where
everyone goes to get it from
well then we need to kind of rethink
what
that space is
um and what rules govern that space you
know is and and and
once we do that we can we can establish
okay well you know but for where we're
sitting right now with section 230 and
all of that they can do more or less
whatever they want
um
so
i think that we should have a
conversation though about what are the
the responsibilities of of these
networks um because they're companies
because they're private companies
they're responding to culture to some
extent how i what about you got people
sitting in positions of power going oh
don't blame me yeah stuff
but but what do you what do you say what
do you say to someone who may say
i mean
come on colin you know uh to say that
these guys have so much power now you
know uh newspapers used to have that
back in the days or radio had that back
in the days of people
reading a single paper right so the
argument would be that the would the
argument be speed of information being
shared speed of information
uh uh like i have an opinion boom five
seconds i can have it out and then
within 10 minutes you know a thousand
people can see it hear it share it with
others so the shareability factor
changes the game today access changes
the game today this changes the game
today everybody's a citizen
journalist today makes it a lot tougher
so how different last question before we
wrap up really curious you know people
are allowed that people are allowed to
assemble they're allowed to order sure
and they're allowed
to do that whether or not you like those
ideas that's that doesn't mean that they
shouldn't be allowed i agree i told i
mean listen i left iran for specifically
because we couldn't do that you know you
were
afraid to go assemble at a church to
you know worship whoever your god was
you you were have to be careful on what
you could say about khomeini god forbid
if they found that you're an anti-humane
guy you you and your family have to be
very careful with it so yes we escape
for many reasons how different you think
2023 elections going to be
uh 2024 elections going to be
than what we had in 2020
will it be very different or will it be
similar
well i think that um
i
think that it will be different in a i
mean i could go into all the ways that i
think digitally it will be different um
she didn't really see deep fakes be a
big factor in the last election cycle i
think that they're going to increasingly
be i mean cheap fakes you can do now and
and they can kind of feel like defects
and i saw people in hunon spheres
believe videos that were completely
absurd um that but think like oh no
that's that's john podesta you're like
that you don't there's no face there's
no anything it's just a blurry image
with some sound in the background that's
not that doesn't prove anything but if
if individuals will buy that well gosh
they'll they'll buy a video that you
know puts his face onto someone else's
body and and then people will just
believe whatever video is already
aligned with their biases and since
we've already been driven in echo
chambers it's more likely that you know
the left is going to believe certain
things the right's going to believe
other things and they're not going to
agree on which things are real which
things aren't and even video evidence is
going to going to have that same kind of
problem around it
and i think that
i think that we're primed now to go into
election cycle where people just aren't
going to trust the trust the results i i
really hope i wish that you know the
biden administration and the states
right now would do paper ballots in
every in every state um
you know that's that's every vote backed
up with a paper ballot just anything we
can do to put more trust in the election
but that's if you thought the last two
election cycles you know people people
didn't trust the results that that's
going to be massively amplified and the
reason i don't think that anything is
going to improve and i don't think the
polarization in this country is going to
de-escalate
is because
none of the problems that have caused
this have been solved
you know we
unless unless we get privacy rights
online
and stop feeding the algorithms with
personalized data
that allows for this level of
manipulation
you know
nothing's going to change unless people
from the right and the left are able to
start talking again and and and can kind
of
even just agree to disagree um unless
you can get to that kind of a place
i just
i i think that we're we're headed in a
in a potentially dark direction you know
i i announced five million dollars i
made a five million dollar offer two and
a half million to trump two and a half
million dollars to obama to have a
three-hour sit-down
and have a conversation together to
address so we can you know address each
other's issue whatever has been because
those are two people we haven't seen
face off to see if we can possibly unite
because i think those two guys
nobody looks at as biden as the face of
the left people still look at obama as
the face of the left and people look at
trump as a face of the right today
uh uh i think we got to figure out a way
to get these guys in a room to talk
whoever these guys are just get in the
room talk
to teach others that if trump and obama
came in the same room together maybe
others can as well i think we need a
little bit more i agree with you uh
listen uh colin really enjoyed uh the
interview i wish we had more time
together but i really enjoyed talking to
you we're gonna put the link below to uh
the mini series the sixth episode queue
into the storm uh where they can go
visit that and we'll put the information
as well for people to be able to find
you with that being said thank you so
much for coming on and being a guest on
valuetainment this was great so much for
the
very thoughtful conversation anytime
appreciate you buddy take care cheers so
what do you think q anon would you learn
anything new comment below if you liked
it give it a thumbs up and if you like
this interview you may enjoy my
interview with alex jones
i think a week after he got
uh suspended permanently banned from a
hundred different social media sites i
interviewed alex jones on 9 11 maybe
three years ago and it was fascinating
if you've never seen it click over here
to watch it take everybody bye
[Music]